from marlins park in miami florida the
mets face the miami marlins in the
opener of a four-game series the
starting pitchers for miami jordan
yamamoto and for the mets fellow
right-hander robert gaselman left
fielder matt joyce at the plate one on
one out bottom of the first
and joyce out to center field nimo not
going to get there it gets all the way
by him vr heading to third he gets the
green light from trey hillman to second
goes joyce no throw and the marlins have
a one-nothing lead
well joyce stays hot and produces great
swing here as he lines it into center
field now nimmo did not get the best of
reeds that's a fact kind of came in and
then back over a little bit and that's
probably an ill-advised dive i know
sometimes in outfield you feel the panic
but look how far away from the ball is
he is as he dives he kind of gives
himself up that's going to allow the
marlins to score a run
bob smith with the bases loaded hits the
first pitch in the air to right center
it's deep and it's over the head of
bertie and hopping up against the wall
conforto is in canoe right behind him
stopping at third is alonzo it's a two
run double for dominic smith and the
mets go in front two to one
dom wasting no time
and unloading a long double his 17th and
18th runs bad at end of the season to
give the mets the lead so the met's able
to cash in on the wildness of yamamoto
and now it's ahmed rosario batting with
first and second
it's hitting the air to right field
pretty well head bernie got turned
around and he can't get to it it hits
off the wall around third and scoring is
smith stopping at third as ramos it's a
double for rosario and it's three to one
new york john bernie who's played a lot
of right field lately for miami got
twisted like a pretzel and rosario winds
up with a double and an rbi
well he just got turned around here
that's uh oh this is just a total botch
job that's a four in right field in
stratimatic good lord and that's going
to be all for jordan yamamoto
so one out and one on now canoe who had
to base it to left and score to run his
first time up he's running
and robbie hits one out to right center
field headed back toward the gap and
it's out of here
robinson canoe with a two run homer
they moved that fence in this year in
right center field about 12 feet closer
than it was before and canoe takes full
advantage of it his third home run of
the year a two two-run shot to make it
5-1 new york well you got to throw a
strike
you want to come inside what are we
talking about that's why they don't like
to do that those sinker ball pitchers
bled out over the plate and you don't do
that and it's up to canoe just killed it
we go to the fifth inning pete alonso
will lead off
he hits the first one in the air to left
field that's deep back toward the wall
goes joyce and it's out of here
pete alonso goes deep his fourth home
run of the year and the mets now lead at
six to one well luis rojas dropped him
down in the batting order to sixth he
had to walk his first time up then
ninfield hit and now pete goes deep
against josh d smith and the mets now of
a five-run lead hopefully that'll get
them going
jonathan vr leads off in the home theft
jonathan vr lifts one to deep center
field back goes nimmo goodbye home run
jonathan vr
and that's how the fifth inning starts
my goodness what an introduction
that first pitch he sees
it's up that's what you want from
familia
first left-handed home run this season
for jonathan vr
this will be pitch number nine from
shaffer to mcneil
and he skies one out to right center
that'll get the run in at least back
goes birdie near the wall to make the
catch tagging at third and scoring
easily as nimmo
mcneil making a bid for an extra base
hit birdie able to run it down but nimmo
comes home on the sacrifice fly to make
it seven to two new york
and that's it deep to right field bernie
just gives this one a look and that is
way out of here into the second deck
robinson canoe pulverizes one his second
two-run homer of the night
a monstrous clock by canoe and it's 9-2
new york he didn't even take a breath
during his 10 days on the injured list
he has come back smoking three hits
tonight including a pair of 2-1 homers
and the mets have opened a seven-run
lead so here's alonzo who's homer
and alonso crushes another one and this
one's going out of here
second of the night for alonso and he
hits a tape measure shot
canoe and alonso go back to back and the
mets are having a party in miami it's
10-2 new york well we go to the ninth
inning and now in the 966th
major league game for logan forsyth this
infielder by trade makes his first
pitching appearance so now billy
hamilton up for the first time in the
game 52 at bat since his last home run
he hits this one out to left field
chasing sierra back a step he makes the
catch and rosario's going to come down
the line and score on the sacrifice fly
for hamilton
so billy has his first rbi as a met
and it's now 11-2
last to the ninth inning franklin
kilomay trying to finish off the night
as lewin diaz will come to the plate
and lewin diaz with the base hit into
center field that will bring home monte
harrison the first major league rbi for
lewin diaz
and john bernie a base hit into left
field that will score diaz everybody
moves up 90 feet
bases loaded two out two runs home in
the ninth for the marlins
as vr tries to keep it going and kilamay
tries to bring it to an end
now the three-two
ball out to right field coming on his
nimmo
and the ball game is over franklin
kilomay goes the last three innings to
get the save robinson canoe and pete
alonso each hit a pair of home runs the
mets match their season high with 11
runs and they win a slog from the
marlins to snap a three-game losing
streak as the mets win tonight 11-4